[ Musique effrayante. ]
[ Rires malsains. ]
[ Rires toujours aussi malsains. ]
Ce perso est cauchemardesque, mais vraiment.
Eh bien, bienvenue à tous, pour passer une mauvaise nuit.
J'espère que vous regardez la vidéo le soir.
Si c'est pas le cas, mettez-là en pause.
Revenez à 23h et faites "play" à 23h.
Ok? On fait comme ça. Personne ne vas le faire.
TROIS HISTOIRES D'HORREUR VRAIES !
ÉPISODE 454, CAR LE CONCEPT MARCHE BIEN !
[ Rires. ]
J'ai lu pas mal d'histoires d'horreur ces derniers temps.
Beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup; je vous avoue.
En plus moi, ai ayant joué à des jeux d'horreurs, je le rappelle!
Je suis pas forcément sensible à certaines histoires.
Donc c'est compliqué de me faire vraiment flipper a...a... avec juste un texte écrit.
Mais! J'ai trouvé des choses très badantes.
Il y a toujours une mécanique précisément qui me fait flipper,
qui me donne des frissons et que je déteste!
C'est la fameuse intrusion!
Par intrusion, je veux dire intrusion chez quelqu'un.
Donc euh, quelqu'un qui vient chez toi, alors que c'est chez toi,
et que tu sais pas qui c'est et il est là.
Et cette mécanique là, ça me fait vraiment flipper.
Il y a deux histoires qui traitent de ça, et une autre qui traite d'autre chose
d'encore plus badant!
Bref! Messieurs, dames, installez vous confortablement dans votre lit!
Éteignez les lumières!
Et allons-y.
Et là, si j'étais un youtubeur stylé,
il y aurait une intro dédiée à ce type de vidéo là.
[ Musique + rires. ]
Première histoire, très courte.
Baptiste vit à New York.
Il habite au deuxième étage d'un immeuble qui fait juste trois étages.
Il est donc au milieu.
Ils ont un vide sanitaire qui connecte du coup ces trois appartements entre eux.
Petit schéma euh... à l'appui.
Approximatif.
Il explique que ni lui, ni ses voisins ne savent réellement pourquoi cette pièce existe
et quel intérêt elle a finalement.
Mais qu'en tout cas, aucun d'eux n'y va.
Et aucun d'eux ne l'utilisent.
Vous, vous sentez
le problème arriver avec cette pièce?
Vous le sentez ou pas?
Un soir Baptiste rentre chez lui.
Il arrive dans son salon et voit une femme
debout sur son escalier de secours,
qui regarde par la fenêtre.
On est à New York,
et à New York il y a des escaliers issues de secours
au cas où il y a un feu.
Et du coup, quand tu empruntes ces escaliers
ben tu passes devant la fenêtre des gens quoi.
Cette femme est donc là, debout à regarder par la vitre.
Et c'est quand même bizarre, parce qu'il faisait encore jour.
Et surtout comment elle a fait pour arriver sur ces escaliers de secours.
En bas, vous savez, il y a une échelle sur un rail
qui s'amène vers le sol et bref.
Elle a réussi à s'y démerder à aller là, on ne sait pas trop comment.
Mais on se doute que du coup ses intentions ne sont pas incroyablement bienveillantes.
[ Rires. ]
C'est le moins que nous puissions dire!
Baptiste s'est jeté par terre
et s'est mis à ramper pour atteindre son téléphone.
Tout en regardant la femme qui était sur les escaliers,
et qui essayait de trouver un moyen d'ouvrir les fenêtres de Baptiste.
Ça y est, j'ai peur, c'est officiel.
J'ai réussi à lui... ptits regards derrière.
Baptiste à enfin pu aller dans sa chambre pour choper son téléphone.
Et pour appeler le propriétaire de l'appartement,
afin qu'ils appellent la police et qu'il y ait une enquête sur ça, quoi.
Après ça, Baptiste est retourné dans son salon
pour voir si elle était encore là.
Et non, aucun visuel.
Mais d'un coup, il a entendu un gros bruit qui venait de son plafond.
Il explique que son plafond, c'est un plafond fait en dalles de liège.
Vous savez, c'est les trucs qu'on peut soulever et décaler.
C'est les plafonds les moins rassurants du monde, qu'on se le dise.
Après avoir entendu du bruit venir de là-haut,
il a donc regardé ce qu'il se passait,
là d'où venait le bruit.
Et il a vu une dalle se soulever, être décalée sur le côté,
et il a vu le reflet de la lumière
dans ce qui s'apparentait à être deux yeux, dans le noir.
Il y a vraiment des bruits, putain.
Il explique alors qu'il a aucune idée de
comment elle a fait pour atteindre le fameux vide sanitaire.
Mais qu'il a chopé un balai,
et qu'il a commencé à taper dans toutes les putains de dalles de son plafond.
Et après un autre long moment, il a arrêté.
Il a compris qu'elle n'était plus là.
Et il s'est décidé du coup à appeler lui-même la police,
et à leur dire de rappliquer en vitesse pour enquêter.
Mais malheureusement ça n'a rien donné.
Les flics sont venus, ils ont checker les chambres,
le salon, le vide sanitaire, le faux plafond, l'issue de secours,
et ça n'a rien donné.
Mais Baptiste a eu des news, quelques jours plus tard de la police.
Puisqu'ils l'ont trouvée dans les escaliers de secours
d'un autre appartement, très proche de chez lui.
Il lui ont dit que c'était, en fait, une personne qui se droguait,
et qu'elle avait été extrêmement violente à leur égard
quand ils ont voulu l'arrêter.
Baptiste explique qu'il est bien content qu'elle ait été chopée.
Mais qui sait pas si c'était vraiment elle dans son faux plafond, ou pas.
Donc si ça se trouve, la personne qui était dans son faux plafond
est toujours en totale liberté!
YES !
C'est bon, vous êtes prêts à passer aux vraies histoires terribles, maintenant?
Vous êtes sûr que vous êtes prêts?
Je vous laisse deux secondes pour réfléchir.
On y va.
Lucie a rencontré, comme beaucoup de filles,
un mec sur Tinder, qui lui plaît.
Ils se sont parlés pendant plusieurs semaines, sans se voir en vrai.
Et ils ont même découvert qu'ils avaient quelques amis en commun.
Ce qui est un truc plutôt rassurant
quand tu rencontres quelqu'un sur Tinder, finalement.
Tu te dis, bon on a quand même des connexions indirectes.
Donc logiquement je ne risque pas de me faire tuer par cette personne, quoi.
Si tu prends le cas extrême.
Lucie explique qu'un soir, elle était un peu en déprime,
et elle avait envie de voir quelqu'un.
Elle a donc appelé un Uber et elle a décidé d'aller chez ce mec.
Qui s'appelle Tim.
Une fois sur place, ils ont commencé par discuter devant la maison, ensemble.
Et Lucie a trouvé que le courant passait encore mieux en vrai.
Elle était ravie.
N'est-ce pas trop parfait comme début d'histoire?
Si ?
Elle lui a notamment parlé de ses problèmes de santé.
Et ça a beaucoup touché Tim,
étant donné que sa soeur est décédée,
et qu'elle avait une maladie proche de celle de Lucie.
Ce détail a son importance!
[ Rires. ]
Ils sont donc rentrés dans la maison.
Et en rentrant, première remarque de Lucie,
la maison ressemblait en gros,
à une sorte d'unité de stockage, mais avec plein de trucs partout, très encombré.
Tim l'a alors emmené dans sa chambre pour "Netflix and chill".
Vous connaissez?
Ils se sont posés dans le lit, ils ont parlé pendant pas mal de temps.
La soirée se finit normalement,
et tout d'eux s'endorment dans le lit de Tim.
Et elle a aucune remarque spéciale à faire,
à part que c'était un peu féminin comme déco, etc.
Mais bon, il fait ce qu'il veut hein.
Mais alors, où ça cloche Lucas?
Attendez, attendez qu'elle se réveille.
Lucie se réveille vers 10h du mat,
à cause d'une horrible odeur!
Elle explique que ça sentait comme s'il y avait
1000 rats décédés sous le plancher de la maison.
La nuit étant passée, Lucie n'avait plus d'alcool dans le sang,
elle avait totalement décuvée.
Et elle avait donc un meilleur sens de l'observation.
Elle se met à regarder autour d'elle,
et elle remarque que dans la penderie
il n'y a QUE des vêtements de fille.
Elle va d'abord se dire que Tim a une copine,
et que c'est les fringues de sa copine.
Et que du coup il a trompé sa meuf avec elle, et c'est chaud.
Elle s'est alors assise sur le lit, et elle a regardé
l'oreiller sur lequel elle venait de passer la nuit.
Et elle constate qu'il n'y avait pas de taie d'oreiller, sur l'oreiller.
Et que surtout, il y avait du sang, du vieux sang séché.
Comme si quelqu'un avait toussé du sang sur son oreiller, en pleine nuit.
Et c'est là qu'elle a une sorte de déclic.
Elle a vu les vêtements de filles dans la penderie,
elle se souvient que Tim lui a parlé de sa soeur
qui été décédée d'une maladie.
Eurêka! Elle comprend qu'elle est probablement dans la chambre de la soeur de Tim.
Elle lui demande alors avec délicatesse,
s'ils viennent de dormir dans la chambre de sa soeur ou pas.
Tim lui répond que oui.
C'est bel et bien la chambre de sa soeur,
et qu'il n'a rien changé, ni lavé depuis qu'elle est décédée.
Et que c'est l'endroit, où elle est décédée dans ses bras.
Et il explique ensuite à Lucie, qu'elle lui rappelle énormément sa soeur.
Qu'il est vraiment, vraiment amoureux d'elle.
Là, ça commence à être très creepy.
Lucie explique qu'elle se sentait très triste pour lui.
Que ce mec là, a dû traverser un truc terrible!
Mais qu'elle pouvait pas rester là, quoi.
Qu'il fallait, qu'elle, qu'elle s'en aille.
C'était trop pour elle.
Elle rentre chez elle et elle décide de ne pas couper les plombs.
Elle garde contact, ils parlent encore un petit peu.
Et après quelques semaines, elle relance pour x raisons,
l'application "Find my Friends".
C'est une application qui permet de géolocaliser tes amis.
Elle lance l'appli et elle remarque un truc horrible,
sa location à elle, a été partagée avec Tim
la nuit où elle a dormi chez lui.
Ce qui veux clairement dire que Tim, pendant qu'elle dormait,
a pris son téléphone et a activé ça dans l'appli.
Elle a alors appelé Tim pour lui expliquer sa découverte
et pour lui dire qu'elle ne voulait plus lui parler,
que ce genre de comportement c'est juste pas possible.
Et c'est là que Tim a complètement changé de personnalité.
Et qui s'est mis à vouloir la faire complètement culpabiliser,
qui s'est mis à dire des trucs du style euh,
Nan mais tu peux pas croire que j'ai fais ça, c'est des bêtises.
T'es vraiment une connasse qui me jette juste parce que mon chat est mort récemment!
WHAAAAT?
Quel est le rapport?
Alors voilà!
C'était l'histoire de Lucie et de Tim, sacré prince charmant.
Et c'était quoi cette odeur?!
Est-ce qu'il a buté son chat?!
Est-ce qu'il a séquestré on sait pas qui?!
Putain, c'est glauque!
On n'aura jamais la réponse et j'espère qu'on ne croisera jamais son chemin.
Alors, les amis,
il est maintenant temps de passer à la troisième histoire.
Celle où il y a GIGA, MÉGA intrusion.
[ Rires. ]
Laissez moi vous raconter l'histoire de Mathilde.
Mariée à Valentin depuis plusieurs années.
Rassurez-vous, Valentin est un homme charmant et très correct.
Et le truc creepy ne vient pas de lui.
Mathilde est tombée malade,
genre une grosse maladie qui la cloue au lit.
Et Valentin a voulu qu'elle prenne du repos pour se remettre de cette maladie.
Ça rend toujours triste quand tu vois ton mec ou ta meuf qui est
trop mal à cause d'une maladie.
Tu lui souhaites le meilleur, tu veux qu'il se rétablisse, donc voilà
tu le pouponnes un peu.
Les parents de Mathilde voulant voir leur petit-fils,
Valentin s'est rendu chez eux avec le bébé.
Et a donc laissé Mathilde se reposer tranquillement à la maison.
Quelques heures plus tard, Mathilde se réveille
parce qu'elle a des douleurs à la poitrine,
parce qu'elle doit allaiter et évacuer.
Et elle a ce fameux dilemme du
comme quand t'as envie de faire pipi en pleine nuit ou tôt le matin.
Rha! J'ai la flemme, je suis tellement bien.
Ouais mais faut que j'y aille, je pourrai pas dormir tant que j'y vais pas.
Ouais, mais j'ai la flemme.
Mais la version poitrine qui fait mal, quoi.
Donc je pense que c'est encore plus désagréable.
Après je n'en sais rien, vous vous en doutez.
Au bout d'un ptit moment, elle commence a être bien réveillée
et elle se rend compte qu'il fait très froid dans la maison.
Elle ouvre les yeux et elle entend la porte d'entrée se fermer.
Elle est donc contente, parce qu'elle se dit:
"Putain, yes je me réveille au moment où Valentin rentre, c'est cool.".
[ Craquements ]
Elle appelle alors Valentin et zéro réponse.
Elle allume la lumière de la chambre, elle allume la lumière de la cuisine,
elle allume toutes les lumières qu'elle peut allumer
pour vérifier qu'elle est bien seule.
Et y a personne dans la maison.
Elle checke si la porte d'entrée est verrouillée.
La porte d'entrée est verrouillée, bref tout va bien.
J'ai peur. Bon ça, ça va pas par contre.
Elle sait que c'était pas un rêve, donc elle envoie un message à Valentin,
pour lui dire "putain j'ai peur, il s'est passé un truc bizarre".
Peu de temps après, Valentin rentre, elle lui explique de vive voix.
Ils mangent et Valentin reste dans le salon
pour dormir avec le bébé.
Alors que Mathilde, elle, dort dans la chambre.
Tout simplement pour dire que Mathilde puisse faire une nuit correcte,
pour qu'elle puisse se reposer vraiment.
Parce qu'un bébé, comme vous le savez ça pleure.
Et elle a clairement pas besoin de ça,
vu comme elle est malade.
Avant de dormir, Valentin s'assure que la porte d'entrée est fermée.
S'assure que toutes les fenêtres sont bien verrouillées.
Et chacun va se coucher.
Mathilde se réveille vers 2h du matin,
à nouveau parce qu'elle doit extraire, elle a mal.
Et elle ressent la même chose que quelques heures avant,
quand elle s'est réveillée et qu'elle était pas bien,
pas à l'aise du tout.
Et elle voit une silhouette au bord de son lit.
Quelqu'un est là, au pied du lit.
Et il fait la même taille et la même corpulence que Valentin, son mari.
Elle lui demande donc d'aller lui chercher un verre d'eau,
pendant qu'elle se prépare à évacuer.
Mais Valentin reste immobile et ne lui répond pas.
Elle lui redemande donc, d'aller chercher un verre d'eau.
Et Valentin lui répond alors: "Non, non, rendors-toi,
j'aime bien te regarder dormir.".
Sauf que ce n'est pas la voix de Valentin.
[ Rires gênés. ]
Mathilde se rue vers sa lampe de chevet pour l'allumer.
Et elle voit un mec parfaitement inconnu
qui se met à rigoler face à elle.
[ Tousse. ]
Nan, n'essayez pas d'évacuer la peur par le nez,
ça ne marchera pas.
Valentin entend le rire, ça le réveille.
Il court rejoindre Mathilde dans la chambre.
Et malheureusement le mec a réussi à prendre la fuite,
avant même que Valentin arrive dans la chambre.
Mathilde et Valentin ont donc tout de suite appelé la police.
Étant à l'étage, la chambre elle est quand même pas mal haute.
Et ils ont pas réussi à comprendre comment le mec
a fait pour venir et aussi pour partir,
sans se blesser en ayant sauté cette hauteur.
Bref, il y a eu investigations et quelques années après,
ça n'a toujours rien donné.
Ils ont jamais retrouvé ce mec,
qui continue probablement à faire ça dans le quartier.
En gros, Mathilde a rencontré un mec qui adore
s'introduire chez les gens en cachette,
et regarder les femmes dormir.
C'est bon pour vous?
C'est tellement badant!
Vous imaginez le traumatisme que tu te prends dans la gueule quand tu vis ça.
C'est horrible!
C'est la fin, les amis, de ce troisième épisode
des trois histoires terrifiantes.
J'espère que ça vous a plu.
On en fait un tous les mois, voilà c'est le petit rythme qu'on a.
Ça me plait et ça me permet d'attendre qui ait vraiment des histoires cool à raconter,
et pas des trucs pas ouf.
Je vous dit à bientôt, dans une prochaine vidéo
un peu moins flippante, ne vous en faites pas!
Et je vous souhaites une très bonne nuit,
une excellente nuit.
Vraiment, fermez bien les yeux,
regardez pas au pied de votre lit si vous vous réveillez en pleine nuit,
ne regardez pas.
À bientôt tout le monde!
Bonne nuit!